voicing on in the frozen sequel that's
that's that's happening you're working
on it right now okay is Disney aware of
the stuff that you're doing online
because you are posting pictures of your
action figure in compromising photos
with another action figure
first of all right and we won't get into
it I don't I have proof but I want to
show it just yet I just want to know why
you're doing this and is Disney aware
okay hey I don't know okay B I was
Kristen before I worked for Disney okay
so I am an autonomous human being and if
I think something's funny I might post
it see it was consensual consensual
between those two action figures yes
well here's the pictures you've been
posting as you was put the first one up
is you and tyrion lanister thank you my
dreams but look it's on I'll type where
this is the origin he doesn't look
consensual for him he looks angry
no no he's into it trust me that's it
into it face okay so when I did we the
boss with Melissa McCarthy and Peter was
in it and when Peter wasn't there in the
days he wasn't there because we all
adored him so much we would keep his
tyrion lanister figurine like at video
village right by the monitors and then
one day someone brought in an on a
figurine and then that day I had too
much time on my hands and I just started
let's do another one this is Exhibit B
let's take a look right
[Applause]
and then Exhibit C right here let's get
into it
so I'm getting a call now that you've
been replaced in the day secret yeah no
it was consensual those dolls were happy
to participate so I think they were
doing some group yoga yeah that's it
that's what you want to say that's how
you want to get out of it 15 seconds of
physical contact will give you an
oxytocin boost and that's maybe that's
what they were doing what's that what
did you like a chemical in your brain
like good like when you like hug someone
or like when you snuggle with someone if
you have 15 full seconds so that you'll
feel you'll get like a boost of oxygen I
didn't know that is a good predictor
wait you're saying that if 15 seconds of
a hug is enough to release chemicals in
my brain and make happy cuz we're
supposed to like as human beings you
need each other we need to communicate
and have physical affection and that's
why when you snuggle with someone it's
so nice he called it test that this is
it okay it works anyway it doesn't have
to be sexual for me this is a sec
[Applause]
you